you know what a really cool one was that
uh that was part of your TED Talk
where there's a rotating thing that you
wear on your shoulders was that hard to
make so for some people haven't seen
your Ted Talk they should of course but
it's uh the best joke
you put how would you call that device
sorry I don't even know I never used it
beyond the Ted Talk really
um yeah but basically it's the shoulder
rig and it has this like almost like
saturn ring looking platform that goes
around I can't even remember what the
problem proposition was that I was
trying to solve variety probably
introduced me yeah maybe in this in an
element of surprise because you can put
popcorn as you did on it and it goes
around as a little hand why is it like a
tiny hand funny I don't know but it just
slams whatever is online into your face
yeah
was that easy to make yeah that one's
fine
I can't
there was I mean my TED Talk was so
yeah for one once again they cut out my
best joke what was the best joke my best
joke they didn't even ask me about it it
was um
so there's this whole lead up where I
built a chopping machine so it's a
machine that chops vegetables and has
two giant knives and it goes and it's
kind of terrifying and I show
a video of it and then it ends on this
GIF of it chopping up a banana and I'm
kind of scrunching up my face being like
and the whole reason I show that project
is because I'm leading it up to the
punch line of
oh and as a bonus this gift right here
is the perfect response if anyone ever
sends you dick pics you don't want
which brought down the house it does it
every time and they cut it out without
asking me because they're like oh but we
wanted people to be able to show it in
classrooms and I was like I have
abandoned the hope of being shown in
classrooms for years ago I think that's
a good joke thank you that's a really
that's a really good one you're you're
okay going sometimes a little bit edgy
I I say that I'm I'm crude and wholesome
because I can be very crude but I also
try really really hard to be a good
person yeah and to like I'll say [__]
and [__] all that stuff which I don't
even think is crude
um but
yeah but I really really try to wield
the power that I have in a thoughtful
way
so
no I I wouldn't call me edgy because I'm
not I don't think it's edgy it's all
like shopping a banana with nice and
saying it's a good gift response to
anyone that sends you dick pics is
definitely not edgy you're correct yeah
funny joke oh yeah it's pretty funny I
feel bad that Ted cut that I mean it's
fine it's like it's a decision that I
made really early on
worth interpret what I'm doing as being
for children which I think is part
because like my projects were always
really colorful and fun
I think it also has some
sprinkles of sexism of being like Oh
it's a woman doing something she must be
doing it for the children and I'm like
[__] the children I'm doing it for
myself
so I think I I would just really early
on decided of like
I'm not gonna try to cater to that which
like
still I mean I get a lot of messages
from parents being like can you please
stop cussing in your videos and I'm also
like
I get it but also that is not what's
going to mess up your kids yeah I really
try to be thoughtful and a decent enough
role model but I'll also acknowledge
that humans [__]
yeah okay somehow that you being able to
say the fu
to this what word word
what do it okay I can't
it sounds better when you say a few it's
it's it's a dance I should oh boy